bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check-up votre magazine santé
bien-être au sommaire de cette nouvelle
édition la Journée nationale des aidants
c'était le 6 octobre une journée entière
consacrée à ces personnes qui
accompagnent un proche malade ou en
situation de handicap nous irons ensuite
au chêné l'hôpital Mignot vient
d'inaugurer son nouveau service de
réanimation son ouverture est prévue à
la fin du mois d'octobre au sommaire
également la colère des pharmaciens nous
avons rencontré les professionnels
yvelinois qui ont largement suivi le
mouvement de grève nationale
le 6 octobre dernier lors de la Journée
nationale des aidants familiaux le
réseau du handicap organisé une réunion
à la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'occasion
d'échanger d'informer et d'épauler ces
personnes qui soutiennent un de leurs
proches William elle et Catherine julato
alors il y a déjà être aidant qu'est-ce
que cela veut dire c'est à cette
première question qu'elle souhaitait
répondre la table ronde organisée par
Géron handicap être aidant pourrait dire
c'est proposer un accompagnement
privilégié d'un proche alors dans un
réseau familial ou amical d'un proche
qui est en situation de handicap qui est
très âgée avec une perte d'autonomie ou
qui est atteint d'une pathologie
invalidante l'occasion aussi pour les
personnes présentes de trouver des lieux
ressources parmi les associations le
pallium qui propose le maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées via des
séjours de répit et des hospitalisations
programmées le but éviter le passage aux
urgences de ces personnes malades et
surtout soutenir ces aidants qui sont
parfois trop isolés le souci c'est que
on n'est pas encore suffisamment dans
une politique d'aide aux aidants en tous
les cas même si la politique est là la
journée d'aujourd'hui en est la preuve
les acteurs de terrain ne sont pas
encore suffisamment dans cette mouvance
là et c'est vrai que bien souvent les
médecins traitant lorsqu'ils nous
appellent puisque nous on est un réseau
de santé donc on peut être interpellé
par les médecins traitants c'est souvent
le jour où il y a une urgence il existe
plus d'une centaine d'associations
d'aides à domicile dans le département
pour s'y retrouver les possibles de
s'adresser à la coordination
gérontologique de son secteur à 50 ans
ni Binel se situe dans les locaux du
mérontais à Mani les hameau là où se
trouve également les locaux de
gérondicap
c'est un témoignage que nous vous
proposons celui d'un mort paient depuis
plusieurs années il se consacre à sa
femme tombée malade il la soutient il
l'accompagne un rôle des dents pas
toujours facile à gérer il nous raconte
son expérience
alors je suis Jean-Louis Lafont j'ai 77
ans
je suis marié nous avons deux enfants
une qui vit aux États-Unis et mon fils
qui habite à un quart d'heure d'ici tout
allait bien jusqu'à
mars 2010
lorsque brutalement ma femme m'a
présenté des troubles
neurologiques qui ont nécessité
un scanner et on a détecté une tumeur au
cerveau il a fallu qu'elle soit opérée
depuis
elle est hospitalisée à l'hôpital de
Chevreuse
où elle en soins longue durée et
actuellement il est en phase de
récupération mais ça va quand même pris
quatre ans donc depuis
mars 2010 je suis à son chevet tous les
après-midi
ce qui change c'est d'abord se retrouver
tout seul quand on rentre le soir c'est
la première chose la solitude alors au
début c'est de solitude elle est
agrémentée par les amis qui téléphone la
famille qui s'inquiète de la santé de
mon épouse donc début j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup avec les sérieux quand même mon
fils qui passait me voir ma fille qui
téléphone et
puis au fil du temps
et bien tout ça s'atténue jusqu'à
pratiquement disparaître en fait tout au
moins pas du côté des enfants au bout de
6 7 mois je voyais plus personne
et
j'ai commencé à plonger parce que
je voyais plus plus de buts plus de
plus d'intérêt autre que celui d'aller
voir ma femme donc je passais je me
levais à midi je déjeunais puis je
partais à l'hôpital j'avais une vie
associative qui était assez importante
brutalement j'ai pu le temps de le faire
donc ce routier
très embêtant pour moi le déclic ça a
été la rencontre de Géron handicap on se
retrouve entre personnes et rencontrant
les mêmes difficultés le fait déjà de
sortir de chez moi
de
m'habiller je dirais
complètement
et non plus être traîné en jean ou en
survêtement
ça a été déjà une prise de conscience
que j'avais besoin d'aller voir les
autres et puis se retrouver avec des
personnes autour d'activités
intéressantes ça m'a donné le goût de
reprendre d'autres activités vous savez
quand on a vécu 50 ans avec quelqu'un
et en fait on se connaît depuis ce 24
ans
donc il est sûr qu'on est très attaché
et la maladie de mon épouse a été pour
moi une catastrophe
c'était un pas de notre vie qui
s'effondrait
donc j'ai prouvé le besoin d'aller la
voir ne serait-ce que pour me rassurer
qu'elle est toujours vivante qu'elle
était toujours là je lui ai fait faire
des exercices de kiné après j'avais
amené des puzzles pour lui faire
travailler le faire travailler la
mémoire
oui le conseil c'est de ne pas
décourager déjà et puis ensuite
de se faire aider
aujourd'hui oui je considère je suis
sorti d'affaires enfin personnellement
je suis sorti d'affaires c'est à dire
que j'accepte sans difficulté mais les
contraintes
la maladie de mon épouse les contraintes
qui en résulte pour moi maintenant c'est
c'est quelque chose que j'accepte et
puis que j'intègre dans ma vie
le centre hospitalier de Versailles
vient d'inaugurer son nouveau service de
réanimation du modernisation profitable
à l'équipe médicale aux patients mais
aussi à leurs proches l'ouverture est
prévue à la fin du mois d'octobre
les locaux sont inaugurés le nouveau
service de réanimation du centre
hospitalier de Versailles et maintenant
prêt à accueillir les premiers patients
après 19 mois de travaux pour un coût
total de plus de 6 millions d'euros la
surface du service est aujourd'hui
doublée et les chambres comme celle-ci
beaucoup plus vaste on passe déjà de 18
à 20 lits avec
20 chambres qui vont être équipées de
façon similaire ce qui va permettre
d'accueillir environ 775 personnes dans
l'année et d'avoir une qualité de
d'accueil des patients une qualité de
vie dans le service augmenter à la fois
pour eux et pour l'équipe paramédicale
l'équipe paramédicale l'une des grandes
gagnantes de cette rénovation elle
bénéficiera notamment d'une nouvelle
salle de soins dotée d'armoires à
pharmacie sécurisée mais surtout d'un
poste infirmier qui aura une visibilité
sur chacune des chambres ça va changer
notre notre travail quotidien
et on va être vraiment plus à l'aise que
dans l'ancien service qui date quand
même de la création de l'hôpital donc de
81 avec quelques aménagements
qui ont eu lieu au cours de ces
dernières années mais ça reste quand
même un service un petit peu obsolète
avant on était très à l'étroit dans des
petites chambres qui étaient pas aux
normes réglementaires de la réanimation
puisque leur animation est normée par
des surfaces des chambres de moins 20
mètres carrés auparavant réservé aux
urgences maintenant déplacées ces
nouveaux locons donc profiter à tout le
monde y compris aux proches des malades
une nouvelle salle d'attente leur sera
dédiée ainsi que des salles d'accueil
l'ancien service de réanimation lui
deviendra une extension de la maternité
les pharmaciens ne décolèrent pas il y a
plusieurs jours les professionnels du
département ont suivi le mouvement de
grève nationale et les officines sont
restés portent close nous avons
rencontré quelques blouses blanches
avant leur départ pour Paris Patrick
Jacques Deluxe pour les images
rideau fermé et affiche placardées sur
les vitrines ce mardi environ 95% des
pharmaciens Yves Lillois ont suivi le
mouvement de grève nationale à la gare
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce matin
quelques blouses blanches ont pris la
direction de Paris avec leurs collègues
ils sont descendus dans la rue pour
protester contre deux mesures projets du
gouvernement la première autoriser la
vente de médicaments accessible sans
ordonnance dans les grandes surfaces ça
peut engendrer des personnes qui savent
pas comment utiliser le doliprane par
exemple parce que ça peut être dangereux
ils peuvent pas poser de questions donc
bah ils vont l'utiliser comme par
eux-mêmes quoi et puis voilà pareil pour
le reste il lui prophène ou s'ils ont un
rhume ils savent pas savoir s'ils ont
une toux grasse une toux sèche voilà
toutes les questions que nous on peut
répondre du côté des consommateurs les
avis sont partagés je préfère aller en
pharmacie
ils apportent des conseils et je préfère
avoir un fard des vrais professionnels
je fais quand même confiance au magasin
pharmacien qui est un conseil quand même
non non je souffle les trucs
par exemple de l'aspirine ou de lui
prendre des choses comme ça si le
Supermarché est équipé d'informations je
ne vois pas de différence autre réforme
voulue par le gouvernement ouvrir le
capital des officines à des actionnaires
non pharmaciens une réforme qui là aussi
soulève l'inquiétude des professionnels
les investisseurs forcément
serait investi dans des grandes régions
mais en fait on aurait une déperdition
des pharmacies en zone rurale et du coup
ce serait catastrophique pour justement
le service de santé publique résultat
des pharmacies pourraient bien voir leur
porte close cette fois-ci définitivement
4000 seraient menacés de pharmos futures
immédiate et donc à travers ces 4000
pharmacies ces 4000 chômeurs et d'autres
suivraient forcément puisque après après
en fait on pourrait pas on pourrait pas
continuer d'exister en ce jour de grève
nationale l'agence régionale de santé
d'Île-de-France avait tout de même
réquisitionné 15 officines dans les
Yvelines
ce numéro de check-up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter vous le savez
place aux traditionnelles agenda du 12
au 19 octobre c'est la semaine mondiale
de l'allaitement maternelle pour
l'occasion des débats des rencontres et
des expositions sont organisées dans
tout le département pour tous les
renseignements n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet de la
Coordination française pour
l'allaitement maternel le 31 octobre une
collecte de sang est organisée à
Versailles rendez-vous de 14h à 19h30 au
niveau de la gare Rive Gauche prêt de
l'Hôtel de Ville check up c'est terminé
merci de votre attention je vous donne
rendez-vous dans un mois d'ici là
portez-vous bien